la suite de notre feuilleton maintenant
et toute la semaine nous vivons une
campagne de recrutement très
particulière puisqu'il s'agit
d'embaucher mille cinq cents saisonniers
pour le parc astérix
hier nous avons vécu les castings des
équipes artistiques aujourd'hui ce sont
les cascadeurs qui passent des épreuves
sportives
ils sont six à suivre cette formation
ça c'est ma bouteille je te prête pas
très bien c'était pas mal vous avez fait
un petit effort
en dépit des apparences ils ne sont pas
tombé dans la potion magique quand il
était petit ici d'ailleurs on ne forme
pas de petits astérix mais des petits
d'artagnan avec jean-pierre ces
cascadeurs débutants préparent le
spectacle des mousquetaires l'un des
huit spectacles du parc
repéré lors du casting c'est le moment
pour carrie de passer un entretien
d'embauché
mais ces voix laisse moi je suis là
responsable recrutement du parc donc
vous avez réussi votre audition en tant
que comédienne donc je vous félicite
elle est plus habitué à interpréter
madonna défilé dans un village gaulois
c'est après le bac j'ai j'ai fait une
école de danse et ensuite j'ai enchaîné
directement à club med world
bercy vous êtes intermittente du
spectacle d'accord vous avez les statuts
vous avez le conserver en venant chez
nous voilà
d'accord c'est peut-être aussi ce que
vous recherchez et pourquoi le parc
montant du cachet 85 euros brut par jour
mais l'assurance pour caroline de
toucher les indemnités
ici on apprend au goulot à être d'un 10
ans et le spectacle des élastiques
quatre cascadeurs apprennent à se
suspendre et à gesticuler dans les airs
contrôler jusqu'à peu encore salto avant
alcoa van gijseghem et c'est bien
contrôler c'est bien chandelle
voilà semaines ces deux fermes 2d des
gens qui vont entrer en spectacle donc
qu'ils ont monté aux élastiques qui vont
savoir jouer la comédie et qui vont
aussi pouvoir danser parce qu'il ya une
partie chorégraphique de danse au sol
stop
prenons fouet les mains sont les
élastiques on remonte sur le trapèze
mais lâche ta main
tu as vu trop tard
suite
votre mission c'est quelqu'un a trouvé
qu'il a emmenés hors les babys jeux de
rôles bonnes pratiques
si certains se préparent à se produire
devant le public les autres anticipe les
attentes du public
prenez à droite la statue d'obélix
normalement à cette heure ci il n'y a
pas d'attenté c'est mon oncle faire de
faire on le fera l'ags ans à faire donc
on sent bien c'est pas un sport de
jeunes filles faible pour les six jeunes
cascadeur c'est le premier cours des
screens s'ils ont tous un certain bout
du rics aucun d'entre eux ne s'est
jusqu'ici retrouvé avec une épée dans la
mare trouve bien elle et y vivre on est
sûr choix on est sur toi tu lui veut
vraiment du mal à lavit
voilà donc je repense à tout ça c'est
bien
il ya des choses qui sont dites
simplement pas tant le bras ou ne fait
pas ça ne recule pas ta main fait des
choses qu'un enfant de trois ans
comprendrait
et que vous que vous ne passiez pas tout
de suite qu est-ce qui est là quelle est
la difficulté là je crois jamais
d'arbres fait que les pieds poings les
armes je galère bien c'est technique
c'est peut être souple en soute les
vrais souple et vous allez remarquer que
c'est tonique aux siens bientôt ils
devront croiser le fer qui sont
interprétant à haute voix un spectacle
de cape et d'épée vous est demandé
d'apprendre votre texte pour quelle date
1 je vis je dis c'est jeudi et saisir un
autre vers l'europe dont la tirade du
duel la balade du duel de cyrano de
bergerac ou la soirée parker jeudi et on
commencera à travailler
inventé le combat rien à dire se fait
engager vous par toutatis un feuilleton
signé stéphane despinoy francis forget
nicolas bertolo la suite bien sûr de vin
c'est la fin de cette édition